in the interim it's going to be andy
dalton at quarterback
for the dallas cowboys coach mike
mccarthy talked yesterday
yesterday about his own experience on
having to go with a backup because he's
had to do it a few times in the past
specifically when he was with the
packers he is
well um i think it depends on you know
who
who's who's playing after you lose a
starter i mean
there was moments there in the past that
um you know we we did some good things
with with our back
our backups but there was moments where
we did not so
uh i think the first step is you have to
make sure
everybody in the room is ready and in in
that backup
quarterback is is ready to play so the
offense can continue to grow and move
forward
especially in a year like this where
it's the first year for all of us
you know we've achieved that with andy
dalton so i have great confidence in
in where we are as an offense and you
know we still need to improve on some
things
and you know we'll still be able to do
that uh with with andy playing
quarterback
you know i remember a time when ted
thompson the former gm of the packers
explained that they did not have a
strong backup to aaron rodgers because
and i kid you not they didn't want
to jinx rogers by having
a great backup yeah it made no sense
then
it makes no sense now no and with with
look without him
in 2013 you look at the reduction in
points 29-4 down to 21-7
without him in 2017 for nine games you
see the reduction 24-4 down to 16-6
and again it's this idea chris that
they they really who's ever been the
great backup quarterback
behind aaron rodgers they've just never
had one no they have not
you know that was that was it's risky
especially when
you know you put so much on aaron
rodgers plate to make plays
and kind of like we've always talked
about carry the offense
it's those type of guys that usually
generally get hurt because they have to
you know play on the edge of
recklessness at times to help their team
win and
that's exactly what happened to aaron
rodgers i mean when he broke his
collarbone both times it's he's
scrambling and trying to make something
happen for the team and got caught in
some bad positions but
uh this is why you pay money
for a backup quarterback because no andy
dalton is not dak prescott but he's
still damn good
and their offense is not gonna have to
change
he's still gonna be able to do
physically just about everything dak
prescott can do now he's going to be
able to do on the same level no
he doesn't have as big as an arm he's
not going to be as good in the pocket
with people around him
and and certainly not as good a runner
but he's still a good athlete and can
throw the ball on the run and do
those things to where uh you know again
i don't think
things will have to change not with that
wide receiving core and that was one of
the great offseason
acquisitions by the cowboys the fact
that they had the vision to go you know
what
our team our offense is awesome our
offense might have to carry the team a
little bit
wait let's make sure we have some
insurance in case one guy goes down to
where
everything doesn't fall apart and this
is uh this is that case right here
yeah and uh you're right and look
they're two and three they're in first
place in the division
and i really do believe that these
circumstances
reduce the expectations just enough to
take a lot of the heat off of the
players maybe some of the heat off of
the coaching staff
and they can just take care of business
in the division try to get better and
try to get to the point where
come january if they are hosting a
playoff game they can win that they can
build some
some momentum build some confidence and
then go into the divisional round and
try to do something that they haven't
done since 1995 which is win the game
that puts them in the nfc championship
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports